Hey, welcome back to 40 Days of Holiness.
Today is day 33, and today we are talking about what
happens after the moment where Christ comes
in and rules by the power of the Spirit, expulses from
our heart
that old self, that old nature that corrupts everything that
we do, and replaces that heart of stone with a heart of flesh.
And so I frequently have people ask me, what happens after that?
Does that mean that everything in my life suddenly is completely perfect?
What if I trust God to give me freedom from sin,
and freedom of, and I repudiate the sin nature, as we talked about
in Romans 6, and believe that Christ has set
me completely free.
When I appropriate those riches by faith,
what happens then? Does it mean that if I find
something in my life that's sinful or that is self-centered
or that is wrong, that it means that it wasn't real back there, nothing ever
happened to me?
What is that? And does it mean that I can ever
go back and become self-centered and self-sovereign again?
Well, let's talk about that. All right?
In Hebrews chapter 12, we're going to look at verse number 15.
All right? So right after the writer of the Hebrews says
to
make every effort to live in peace with everyone and to be holy, for without
holiness, no one will see the Lord.
The next thing he says is,
"See to it that no one falls short of the grace of God."
Okay, so the full possibilities of grace.
So if Bill Gates offered to buy you a car and said money was no object,
you wouldn't settle for a used Volkswagen.
You want everything. "See to it that no one falls
short of the grace of God and that no bitter root
grows up to cause trouble and defile many."
Let's unpack that a little bit because I believe that what he's doing there is
using an analogy, a metaphor for the
sin nature. And he says, "See to it that no bitter root
springs up," and bears bitter fruit, basically,
and causes the defiling of many. Let me give you an analogy, all right?
Let's use this analogy, and it isn't a perfect one, but I think it's an
appropriate one. Let me see if I can explain.
So in your life, let's imagine that the tree of
sin is in your life, all right? And that out of this
nature of sin, this root system, all sorts of evil is
produced. So you have the
tree of sin producing nature of sin, producing actions of sin in your
life. Right? And so in salvation, praise God,
Jesus comes along and cuts off this
tree. Thank the Lord. I'm glad to hear that it can happen, right?
That God can cut off and deal with all of those actions and that
living in sin in our life. And yet, you know
what happens if you've ever cut a tree down
and the tree still was alive and healthy at the time.
You know what happens after that. Right?
I just had to do it with one of my trees a while back because I cut one down, and
all these little sprigs started coming up from the stump.
Over here, they're all growing up.
And what's going to happen is,
if I don't take care of that, there's going to be a new tree,
and I'm going to step on more of those little annoying
spiky balls in my backyard. I'm going to have lots
more
fruit coming that I don't want from the
life that is still in
this right here.
There's going to be more results from that.
Now,
the next thing that people say then is, well, if the tree is cut down,
and if by grace, God can not just deal with the acts
of sin, but also the power of it, the presence of it
in my life, not just actions, but nature as well.
If God can take out not just the tree, but also the
stump,
then what?
Well, let me push the analogy just a little bit further, okay?
And you
can only push analogies so far because they get into unbiblical
things, but I think this may be helpful for you to understand.
This fruit, if you've ever known what a tree does, you've ever had an apple tree in
your backyard, it drops fruit.
Right? It drops apples all over the place.
And when you drop that fruit, it's nasty, and it
attracts bugs, and it squishes and gets
under your feet and gets your shoes nasty,
and smells bad, and it rots.
And I would just tell you that after this is cut down,
and after the nature of sin has been removed from your heart,
what next? Well,
you're walking along in your life, and you step on something,
and it squishes.
You know what I'm talking about? You know the tree is gone.
You know by God's grace, you believe, and you trust that God
has done what He promised and removed the nature, cleansed the
nature of sin from your heart by straightening you back out
so that you love God with all your heart, soul, mind, and strength, not just
partially, not with a divided heart, but with a whole one.
And you step on something that squishes.
What are you supposed to do with that?
Well,
here's the thing. What I want to ask, what I want to encourage you to ask is, and
I'm going to write this on here real quick because if we were sitting across the
coffee shop table, I would do this.
Is it a root,
or is it a fruit?
What I just found in my life,
that attitude, that action, that thought pattern, that
way I responded, that way of being in the world right now,
that I'm not happy with that. I feel like it was wrong. It was sinful.
Was it a root
or was it a fruit?
Was it this right here? I found something that squished still in my life or was it
the other? Let me give you another analogy for this or another idea
here.
We have two different things that we're dealing with here.
One is self-sovereignty, and the essence of the sin
nature is self-will, self-sovereignty.
I want to be in charge. That's the essence of the sin nature.
Now,
self-centeredness can be these patterns
up here.
They can be just automatic ways. I automatically assume that the world
revolves around me in my relationships or in my marriage or in my
interactions with my boss or my coworkers.
I just assume that the world revolves around me because that's the way
I've always thought.
And even after Jesus deals with this,
there's still some
self-centered patterns and thoughts and
ways of behaving in my life that I've never even noticed before.
I'm not conscious of them. They're just present because God hasn't
pointed them out to me yet. And I'm walking along
and something squishes and smells bad,
and it's nasty.
What do I do? Here's what I do. I say, "Is that a root?"
Am I self-sovereign in this area and am I just wanting my way
regardless of what God says? Or is it just a pattern of
self-centeredness that I've never noticed before,
but I want to scoop up right now and I'm going to get rid of it because I don't
want any bitter roots growing up in my life.
I don't want the seeds of sin in that bad habit that I've
never noticed before. I don't want those seeds to germinate and
create a new bitter root that springs up and bears bitter
fruit in my life.
So here's what you do.
Is it a root or is it a fruit? If the Lord says to you, "Yes, you're
still self-sovereign. You want your way regardless."
If that's true, then let's be filled with the Holy Spirit and let's take care of
that. Let's get rid of the sin nature.
If it's not true,
then let's scoop up the old rotten fruit of self-centeredness and let's get rid of
it. Let's not say, "Well, that can't be rotten fruit.
I know I'm holy. I know I'm made holy. I'm filled with the Holy Spirit.
Can't be for me. I don't have any room." Oh, no.
Let's be honest and let's say, "That was wrong."
I've got a pattern there of self-centered behavior and thinking, and I
need to scoop that up and get rid of it, or it'll germinate, and I'll have a
brand-new root of bitterness springing up.
You need to be honest with yourself,
and you need to deal with it, but don't throw away your confidence in what God has
done for you. Don't cast it out just because you found something.
Let's be honest. Let's deal with it, and then let's move on
forward. That's what I wanted to share with you today. God bless.
Talk to you next time.